>>> LADIES AND GENTLEMEN,
PLEASE SILENCE YOUR CELL PHONES
AND MOBILE DEVICES AT THIS
TIME.
THANK YOU.
>> [ APPLAUSE ]
>> GOOD AFTERNOON AND WELCOME.
I AND JOHN COATSWORTH , THE
PROVOST OF COLUMBIA UNIVERSITY
AND IT'S MY DISTINCT PLEASURE
TO BE ABLE TO INTRODUCE TO YOU
TODAY, HIS EXCELLENCY LUIS
GUILLERMO SOLC RIVERA,
PRESIDENT OF THE REPUBLIC OF
COSTA RICA . LET ME BEGIN BY
THANKING THE INSTITUTE OF LATIN
AMERICAN STUDIES FOR
COSPONSORING THIS EVENT.
AND I WOULD LIKE TO ACKNOWLEDGE
THE PRESENCE HERE OF THE
ADMINISTER OF FOREIGN AFFAIRS
MR. GONZALES AND -- I WOULD
ALSO LIKE TO THANK YOU ALL AND
ALL OF THE MEMBERS OF THE
DELEGATION FROM COSTA RICA THAT
ARE HERE TO JOIN US AS WELL AS
CHAPLAIN DAVIS AND PROFESSOR --
WHO ARE ALSO PARTICIPATING.
HE WAS BORN IN 1968, THE SON OF
A SHOEMAKER.
HE SPENT HE RECEIVED HIS DEGREES
FROM THE UNIVERSITY AND TULANE.
HE HAS TAUGHT AT THE UNIVERSITY
OF MICHIGAN AND FLORIDA
UNIVERSITY.
HIS POLITICAL CAREER HAS
INCLUDED HIGH-LEVEL POSITIONS
INCLUDING AMBASSADOR AT LARGE
FOR CENTRAL AMERICAN AFFAIRS
AND DIRECTOR GENERAL FOR
POLICY.
UNDER HIS LEADERSHIP COSTA RICA
HAS BEEN LAUDED FOR ITS EMBRACE
OF SUSTAINABLE DEVELOPMENT AND
THE QUALITY OF LIFE ITS
CITIZENS ENJOY.
THE COUNTRY SITS REGULARLY ATOP
THE HAPPY PLANET INDEX, KNOWN
FOR ITS HIGH LIFE EXPECTANCY,
LOW ECOLOGICAL FOOTPRINT IN THE
OVERALL WELL-BEING OF ITS
PEOPLE.
IT'S A GREAT HONOR TO WELCOME
THE PRESIDENT BACK TO COLUMBIA
THIS YEAR. HE SEEMS ALWAYS TO
BE ENGAGED IN THE MOST
TRACTABLE AND CRITICAL
DECISIONS AND CONCERNS OF THE
DAY. LAST YEAR HE CAME TO
MORNINGSIDE HEIGHTS TO DISCUSS
THE MIGRATION CRISIS THAT
CONTINUES TO GRIP LATIN AMERICA
AND THE WORLD.
YOU MAY REMEMBER THAT HIS
COUNTRY WAS AND REMAINS AT THE
CENTER OF THAT CRISIS WITH
MIGRANTS FLEEING EL SALVADOR,
HONDURAS AND VENEZUELA TO SEEK
REFUGE IN UNITED STATES.
TODAY PRESIDENT SOLC RIVERA IS
HERE  TO SPEAK OF ANOTHER ISSUE
THAT THREATENS GLOBAL
STABILITY, THAT IS NUCLEAR WAR.
HE WAS PART OF A CONFERENCE AT
THE UNITED NATIONS TO DRAFT A
TREATY BANNING NUCLEAR WEAPONS.
IN JULY 120 NATIONS VOTED TO
ADOPT THE AGREEMENT, THE FIRST
OF ITS KIND.
YESTERDAY AT THE U.N. NATIONS
BEGAN SIGNING THAT DOCUMENT .
AS EXPECTED, THE 9 COUNTRIES
THAT POSSESS NUCLEAR WEAPONS
INCLUDING THE UNITED STATES DID
NOT PARTICIPATE.
MOST MEMBERS OF NATO ALSO
ABSTAINED PICK SOME CRITICS
CONTEND THE AGREEMENT WILL DO
LITTLE TO DETER COUNTRIES LIKE
NORTH KOREA, RUSSIA AND CHINA
FROM KEEPING THEIR NUCLEAR
ARMS.
SUPPORTERS BELIEVE THEIR ACTION
WILL ADD TO THE MOMENTUM THAT
WILL IMPEL NATIONS TO AGREE TO
THE PLEDGE THAT PRESIDENT OBAMA
MADE WHICH IS THE GOAL OF
ELIMINATING NUCLEAR WEAPONS
ALTOGETHER.
I'M SURE YOU ARE EAGER TO HEAR
ABOUT THIS ISSUE FROM
PRESIDENTS HE'S -- PRESIDENT
SOLC TODAY.
HIS  TALK IS TITLED, THE END OF
NUCLEAR WEAPONS.
PLEASE WELCOME HIS EXCELLENCY
LUIS GUILLERMO SOLC RIVERA,
PRESIDENT OF THE REPUBLIC OF
COSTA RICA.
WELCOME BACK.
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND GOOD
MORNING TO ALL.
I DO THINK, ON BEHALF OF MY
DELEGATION AND MYSELF, [
INDISCERNIBLE - INTERMITTENT
AUDIO ] INSTITUTE OF LATIN
AMERICAN STUDIES AND ALL OF YOU
FOR ALLOWING ME TO COME AND
SHARE WITH YOU SOME THOUGHTS ON
THIS VERY IMPORTANT ISSUE  OF
DENUCLEARIZATION.
WHY IS IT THAT COSTA RICA
CONTINUES TO SUPPORT THIS
PATHWAY TOWARD A MORE SECURE
WORLD, FREE OF NUCLEAR WEAPONS
AND BUILD UPON THE NOTIONS OF
INTERNATIONAL SOLIDARITY, PEACE
AND JUSTICE? IN PREPARING FOR
THIS LECTURE, I PREPARED A BIG
SPEECH, BUT THEN I REALIZED
THAT MAYBE IT WOULD BE MORE
INTERESTING TO PROPOSE A
DIFFERENT APPROACH TODAY. SO
WHAT I AM GOING TO DO IS I WILL
GIVE YOU A 10 MINUTE OPENING
REMARK, PRESENTATION.
THEN I AM GOING TO ASK
AMBASSADOR ELAINE WHITE WHO
PRESIDED OVER THE COMMISSION
THAT DRAFTED THE CONVENTION TO
OUTLAW NUCLEAR WEAPONS, TO COME
AND DISCUSS.
THEN YOU GET TWO SPEAKERS FOR
THE PRICE OF ONE AND IT WILL BE
MORE INTERESTING.
AND YOU GET THE LEAD FIGURE IN
THE NEGOTIATION WHO WAS OUR
AMBASSADOR TO THE YOU AND
ORGANIZATION IN GENEVA, TO HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE WITH
YOU THE HIGHLIGHTS OF THE
NEGOTIATIONS. AS A PROFESSOR,
AS AN ACADEMIC, I HAVE BEEN A
PROFESSOR FOR 35 YEARS -- I'VE
ALWAYS TREASURE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO LEARN FROM THE MAKERS OF
THESE INTERNATIONAL AGREEMENTS,
THEIR EXPERIENCES -- [
INDISCERNIBLE - INTERMITTENT
AUDIO ] HOW THE INTER-DEALINGS
-- INNER DEALINGS OF THE
NEGOTIATIONS WENT ABOUT.
SINCE WE DON'T HAVE THE
LIMITATIONS OF SECRECY, AT
LEAST I DON'T, MAYBE SHE HAS TO
BE MORE -- LESS CANDID THAN I
BUT I'M SURE SHE WON'T BE.
SHE IS ALSO A PROFESSOR.
I THOUGHT IT WOULD BE
INTERESTING SIMPLY TO HEAR SOME
OF HER INSIGHTS TO THE PROCESS
AND HOW SHE SEES, FROM THE
INSIDE OF THE SYSTEM, THE
UNITED NATIONS SYSTEM, THE
LIKELIHOOD OF THE TREATY TO
CONTINUE UNRAVELING OVER THE
NEXT FEW YEARS.
JUST YESTERDAY, 50 OUT OF THE
ORIGINAL 122 CREATORS OF THE
TREATY SIGNED IT.
WE NOW SEE THAT PROCESS UNDERWAY
. ONCE WE HAVE 50 RATIFICATIONS
, AND THERE WERE 2 WITH 3
YESTERDAY AS OF THE TIME OF THE
SIGNING CEREMONY, THEN THE
TREATY WILL ENTER INTO EFFECT.
WE ARE VERY HOPEFUL THAT THIS
WILL HAPPEN IN THE NEXT FEW
YEARS.
AT ANY RATE, LET ME BEGIN BY
SAYING THAT THE ASPIRATION OF A
NUCLEAR FREE WORLD IS SOMETHING
THAT MAKES SENSE.
I SAY THIS BECAUSE QUITE
FRANKLY, SOMETIMES WE GET TOO
PHILOSOPHICAL ABOUT IT I THINK
THERE IS A CASE TO BE MADE
ABOUT THE MORALITY OF NUCLEAR
WEAPONS AND HOW WE SHOULD LOOK
AT IT. SOMETIMES I HAVE PROPOSED
, FOLLOWING THE LOGIC THAT
ANOTHER COSTA RICA PRESIDENT
ONCE USED; FOR ALL PRACTICAL
PURPOSES THE WAY IN WHICH WE
DEAL WITH DRUGS AND THE WAY
DRUGS ARE SEEN IN MANY
DEVELOPED COUNTRIES ARE FOR
MORAL PURPOSES, EQUAL TO WHAT
ONE CAN SAY ABOUT WEAPONS.
REGULAR WEAPONS AND WEAPONS OF
MASS DESTRUCTION, WHAT IS THE
ULTIMATE MORAL DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN SELLING A PRODUCT THAT
KILLS WHITE AND NONWHITE
YOUNGSTERS IN THE DEVELOPED
WORLD TO THAT LOGIC OF WEAPONS
THAT KILL NONWHITE AND WHITE
YOUNG PEOPLE IN THE THIRD
WORLD?
IT'S THE SAME THING.
IT'S NO DIFFERENCE AT ALL.
FROM A MORAL POINT OF VIEW --
BUT BEYOND THE ETHICS OF WAR,
WHICH CAN BE SO COMPLICATED AND
SO ABSURD, THERE IS A QUESTION
OF, DO WE WANT TO SURVIVE OR
NOT.
OBVIOUSLY, THIS TIME AROUND IN
THIS 72nd GENERAL ASSEMBLY OF
THE UNITED NATIONS, WE HAVE
BEEN TALKING ABOUT THAT ALL THE
TIME.
WE DID THAT WHEN WE TALKED
ABOUT CLIMATE CHANGE, WHOSE
COMMITMENTS IN THE PARIS
ACCORDS AND COSTA RICA
CONTINUES TO UPHOLD AT ALL
COSTS.
WE FEEL THERE SHOULD BE NO
REGRESSION WHATSOEVER OF THOSE
AGREEMENTS AND THE WORLD SHOULD
STAND VERY FIRMLY TO ENSURE
THAT THE VERY DIFFICULT --
DIFFICULTY CRAFTED AGREEMENT
MAY MOVE FORWARD.
IT MAY BE IN THE CASE OF
NUCLEAR WEAPONS, INCLUSION, AND
IN PARTICULARLY -- AND IN
PARTICULAR THAT OF WOMEN WHICH
WE HAVE BEEN FOSTERING STRONGLY
IN THE UNITED NATIONS AS PART
OF A HIGH-LEVEL PANEL THAT WAS
CONVENED BY THE SECRETARY-
GENERAL OF THE UNITED NATIONS.
COSTA RICA HAS INSISTED IN THE
NEED OF WOMEN TO BE PART OF --
TO BE INCLUDED CREATIVELY,
FORCEFULLY AND DECENTLY INTO
THE WORLD'S ECONOMY AND THEY
SHOULD BE ECONOMICALLY
EMPOWERED, WHICH IS THE NEXT
GENERATION OF AGREEMENTS THAT
IS MUCH NEEDED, OTHER THAN THE
POLITICAL ONES.
, GIVING WOMEN THE OPPORTUNITY
TO HAVE EQUAL POSITIONS IN THE
ECONOMY, WE HAVE BEEN UPHOLDING
THAT.
WE HAVE BEEN TALKING ABOUT
ISSUES UPON WHICH THE FUTURE OF
HUMANITY DEPENDS.
YES, THERE IS A DEBATE, CLEARLY
, REGARDING THE CONVENIENCE OF
OF HAVING OR NOT HAVING WEAPONS
OF MASS DESTRUCTION SUCH AS
NUCLEAR WEAPONS, CURTAILED BY
INTERNATIONAL AGREEMENTS.
IN FACT THERE IS A DISCUSSION
ABOUT MULTILATERALISM, WHETHER
THE LOGIC OF INTERNATIONAL
SOLIDARITY SHOULD BE SHOULD BE
IMPOSED UPON OR FOSTERED IN
ORDER TO LIMIT THE INCAPACITY
OF STATES TO DO WHATEVER THEY
WANT -- THAT WAS CLEARLY POISED
IN THE UNITED NATIONS THIS
WEEK.
WE FEEL VERY STRONGLY THAT IT
ALSO COMES TO BE A MATTER OF
COMMON SENSE.
>> WE WANT TO SURVIVE OR DO WE
NOT?
ARE WE WILLING TO MAKE SMALL
NATIONAL SACRIFICES IN ORDER TO
ENSURE THAT THE LARGER CHARGES
ARE ADEQUATELY DEALT WITH AND
TO IS THERE TO DO THE JOB? WITH
NUCLEAR MATTERS, THIS IS
CLEARLY THE CASE. COSTA RICA,
AS YOU KNOW IS A COUNTRY THAT
HAS NO ARMY.
IN 1948 WE ABOLISHED THE ARMED
FORCES AS A PERMANENT
INSTITUTION.
[ TECHNICAL DIFFICULTIES ]
>>> YES, IT'S TRUE THAT ANY
COUNTRY BEARING NUCLEAR WEAPONS
CAN PUSH THE BUTTON AND DO A
HORRIBLE MESS AROUND THE WORLD.
THAT CAN BE DONE WITH OR WITHOUT
A TREATY.
THAT'S THAT.
AND SO LET US ALL PRAY TO OUR
DIFFERENT -- IN OUR DIFFERENT
RERELIGIOUS UNDERSTANDING THIS
MAY NOT HAPPEN.
BUT IF WE'RE ABLE TO BUILD UP A
HUMAN UNDERSTANDING OF
CONVENTIONS, OF LAWS AND NORMS
AND OF POLITICAL LOGICS THAT
COULD PREVENT THAT, WE SHOULD
AND WE MUST DO IT FOR THE SAKE
OF THE REST OF HUMANITY THAT HAS
NOT BEEN BORN YET.
AND ALL OF US ARE IN ONE WAY OR
ANOTHER RESPONSIBLE FOR OUR
WELL-BEING AS SOMEBODY ELSE WAS
RESPONSIBLE FOR OURS BACK IN THE
PAST.
I'M EXTREMELY GRATE FLT WITH THE
122 COUNTRIES THAT AGREED UPON
THE TREATY, I'M VERY GRATEFUL
AND ALSO VERY HONORED THAT A
COSTA RICAN WOMAN CHAIRED THE
COMMITTEE THAT PUT TOGETHER THIS
CONVENTION AND SHE'S ALSO BEEN A
PROFESSOR.
SHE'S AN ACADEMIC AND A MEMBER
OF THIS COMMUNITY.
WE'RE USEFUL AFTER ALL WHEN SOME
PEOPLE THINK THE UNIVERSITIES
COULD BE CLOSED WITH NO
CONSEQUENCES.
AND NOW I WOULD LIKE TO GIVE HER
THE OPPORTUNITY TO TELL US A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE PROCEDURE,
HOW THIS TREATY, THIS CONVENTION
WAS CRAFTED.
AND WHAT ARE SOME OF THE DETAILS
THAT WOULD BE INTERESTING FOR
SUCH AN AUDIENCE TO UNDERSTAND
THE IMMENSITY OF THE TASK THAT
WE HAVE IN FRONT OF US.
AS A SMALL COUNTRY, COSTA RICA
HAS VERY LITTLE POSSIBILITY TO
BE A WORLD ACTOR IN TERMS OF,
YOU KNOW, THE LARGER PICTURE.
WE ARE SMALL.
BUT WE DO HAVE THE MORAL
AUTHORITY TO CALL FOR
INTERNATIONAL PEACE.
BECAUSE THIS IS HOW WE HAVE BEEN
ABLE TO SURVIVE IN A VERY
DIFFICULT WORLD.
AND 72 YEARS AFTER THE
EXPLOSIONS IN JAPAN AND BEARING
IN MIND THAT THERE ARE STILL
PEOPLE WHO ARE SUFFERING FROM
THOSE IMPACTS WHO HAVE BEEN VERY
PRESENT ALONG THE NEGOTIATION OF
THIS TREATY, THAT WE CAN STILL
DO A LOT TO PREVENT AND TO MAKE
IT UNNECESSARY TO RESTORE TO
NUCLEAR WAR AS A SYMBOL OF THE
NEW TIMES WE LIVE.
SO LET US BE OPTIMISTIC AND
HOPEFUL THAT IN SHAPING THIS NEW
WORLD, WE COULD DO IT ON THE
BASIS OF JUSTICE AND PEACE AND
SUSTAINABLE DEVELOPMENT TO ALL.
AND I NOW WOULD LIKE TO
INTRODUCE YOU TO AMBASSADOR LANE
WHITE.
AND THEN QUESTIONS.
I WOULD LIKE EVERYBODY TO FEEL
WELCOME TO ASK QUESTIONS BOTH TO
AMBASSADOR WHITE, TO MYSELF, AND
TO PARTICIPANT IN WHAT I HOPE
WILL BE A VERY INTERESTING
DEBATE FOR THE REST OF THE TIME
AVAILABLE FOR THIS CONFERENCE.
THAUNS VERY MUCH.
AMBASSADOR?
-- THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
>> GOOD MORNING TO YOU ALL.
I WOULD LIKE TO SAY I AM VERY
HONORED TO BE ABLE TO SHARE WITH
WITH THE PRESIDENT.
IT HAS BEEN A VERY RENOWNED
SCHOLAR IN COSTA RICA FOR MANY
YEARS.
I AM HAPPY TO BE ABLE TO SHARE
THIS EXPERIENCE AND ALSO THE
KNOWLEDGE THAT WE HAVE GAINED IN
THIS PROCESS.
ONE OF THE FIRST QUESTIONS THAT
I HAVE BEEN ASKED IS WHY COSTA
RICA?
IT'S HIGH POLITICS AND YOU DON'T
HAVE AN ARMY.
HOW CAN YOU CONTRIBUTE TO THIS
PROCESS IF YOU DON'T HAVE A
KNOWLEDGE ABOUT MILITARY
AFFAIRS?
SO THE FIRST ISSUE -- THE FIRST
RESPONSE TO THAT IS WE DO
UNDERSTAND THE NATURE OF
INTERNATIONAL POLITICS AND
INTESHL POLITICS OF DISARMAMENT
WHICH IS ESSENTIAL FOR
CONDUCTING THIS PROCESS.
BUT AT THE SAME TIME, COSTA RICA
IS AN EXPERT IN DECISION MAKING
WITHIN THE RULE OF LAW.
WE ARE A CONSOLIDATED DEMOCRACY.
AND IT IS IN OUR DNA TO KNOW HOW
TO CONDUCT DECISION MAKING WITH
THIS INCLUSIVE PROCESS THAT IS
AT THE SAME TIME RESPECTFUL OF
THE RULE OF LAW.
AND AN INTERNATIONAL DIPLOMATIC
CONFERENCE THAT HAS BEEN CALLED
FOR, IT'S A VERY FORMAL DECISION
MAKING PROCESS.
SO THE FIRST KRUGS THAT WE GAVE
THIS -- CONTRIBUTION THAT WE
GAVE THIS PROCESS IS A VERY
ENTRENCHED KNOW HOW WE HAVE STO
CONDUCT PROCESSES AND
TRANSPARENT AND INCLUSIVE AND
VERY RESPECTFUL OF THE RULES.
SECONDLY, WE HAVE BEEN INVOLVED
IN DEVELOPMENT THROUGHOUT THE
YEARS.
AND WHEN THE PRESIDENT WAS THE
DIRECTOR GENERAL OF FOREIGN
POLICY, HE PROMOTED A
COMPREHENSIVE CONVENTION ON
NUCLEAR DISARMORMENT BACK IN THE
YEAR 1996.
BUT WE WERE NOT DISCUSSING A
COMPREHENSIVE CONVENTION.
THE GENERAL ASSEMBLY IN DECEMBER
OF 2016 TOOK THE DECISION TO
QUEEN A NEGOTIATING KWOFRNS TO
PROHIBIT NUCLEAR WEAPONS.
THE FIRST THING THEY DID WAS TO
PROVIDE A VERY STRAIGHTFORWARD
MAN DATE FOR THIS CONFERENCE.
WE NEGOTIATE A TREATY THAT FIRST
OF ALL STRENGTHEN AND COMPLIMENT
THE CURRENT ARCHITECT WHICH YOU
ARE.
THIS IS IMPORTANT BECAUSE WE ARE
NOT CREATING A NORM FROM
SCRATCH.
WE WERE CREATING A NORM ALREADY
FROM THE KNOWLEDGE THAT WE HAD
IN THE SYSTEM OF WHAT WORKS,
WHAT DOES NOT WORK.
ESPECIALLY, ALSO, DEPARTING FROM
THE ALREADY AGREED LANGUAGE IN
OTHER TEXTS AND TREATIES, WHICH
WAS A VERY IMPORTANT FACTOR OF
WHY WE WERE ABLE TO FINISH WITH
I NEGOTIATION IN THREE WEEKS,
WHICH IS A RECORD TIME.
MENTION VERY BRIEFLY SOME
HIGHLIGHTS ABOUT THE CONTENT OF
THE TREATY AND THEN WE WILL
REFER TO THE PROCESS.
FIRST OF ALL I WOULD MENTIONED
THREE ASPECTS OF THE TRINITY
THAT I THINK IT'S VERY
IMPORTANT WE KNOW AS CITIZENS
OF THE WORLD.
FIRST OF ALL, NUCLEAR WEAPONS
WERE THE ONLY WEAPONS OF MASS
DESTRUCTION THAT HAVE NOT BEEN
PROHIBITED IN INTERNATIONAL LAW.
THE FIRST THING THAT THIS
TREATY DOES , ARTICLE 1 IS
TRYING TO TAKE THAT
PROHIBITION.
IT HAS A VERY CATEGORICAL
PROHIBITION FOR A WIDE RANGE OF
ACTIVITIES RELATED TO NUCLEAR
WEAPONS, FROM DEVELOPMENT
TESTING -- DEVELOPMENT,
TESTING, PRODUCTION,
MANUFACTURING, ACQUISITION,
POSSESSION, TRANSFER, USE OR
THREATENING TO USE NUCLEAR
WEAPONS. THIS WAS A VERY
CONTROVERSIAL LAST BIT BECAUSE
BY PROHIBITING THE THREAT OF USE
, ONE IS ALSO DELEGITIMIZING
NUCLEAR DETERRENCE. IT'S ALSO
PROHIBITED TO ASSIST OR
ENCOURAGE PROHIBITED ACTS AND
TO ALLOW OTHER [ INDISCERNIBLE
] OR DEPLOY NUCLEAR WEAPONS.
IT'S VERY COMPREHENSIVE FOR
PROHIBITION NORMS.
IN ADDITION, IT WILL BE EASY TO
NEGOTIATE A TREATY AMONG NON-
NUCLEAR STATES.
THAT WAS THE INITIAL FOCUS OF
THE TREATY.
THAT THE CONFERENCE WAS
COMPLETELY DETERMINED TO OPEN
THE DOOR FOR NUCLEAR STATES TO
JOIN THE TREATY FROM DAY ONE.
I CREATED A VERY IMPORTANT
COMPLEXITY IN THE NEGOTIATIONS
SO THAT WE CREATE NORMS AND
PROCEDURES, NOT ONLY FOR THE
NONNUCLEAR STATES BUT ALSO
NUCLEAR POWERS.
THAT MEANS A STATE THAT HAS
POSSESSED NUCLEAR WEAPONS AND
THEN DESTROYED THE NUCLEAR
WEAPONS, THEN CAN JOIN THE
TREATY HAVING BECOME A NON-
NUCLEAR WEAPONS STATE.
THEN IN ADDITION THERE ARE
PROHIBITIONS FOR STATES TO
ADHERE TO THE TREATY BY
COMMITTING TO SUBMIT A PROPOSAL
FOR THE DESTRUCTION OF THEIR
NUCLEAR PROGRAMS WHICH HAS TO BE
APPROVED BY THE CONFERENCE OF
STATES.
OF COURSE THEY CAN JOIN BUT
THEY HAVE TO COMPLETE CERTAIN
REQUISITES.
IN ADDITION WE WERE ABLE TO
ESTABLISH AN APPROPRIATE
INSTITUTIONAL SETTING TO
FURTHER DEVELOP ALL THE ISSUES
THAT WE WERE NOT ABLE TO
NEGOTIATE AT THIS MOMENT
BECAUSE OF THE COMPLEXITY OF
NEGOTIATING NUCLEAR DISARMAMENT
AND ITS VERIFICATION. THIS IS
WELL BEYOND THE TIME WE WOULD
HAVE TO NEGOTIATE.
WE GAVE THE CONFERENCE TO
SUPPORT THE RESPONSIBILITY TO
FURTHER DEVELOP THE MEASURES,
LEGALLY BINDING IN THE SHAPE OF
ADDITIONAL PROTOCOLS TO THE
TREATY, TO FURTHER DEVELOP THE
MEASURES FOR NUCLEAR DISARMAMENT
. IN ADDITION, WHICH IS ALSO
INTERESTING, CONSISTENT WITH
OTHER INTERNATIONAL HUMAN
RIGHTS LAWS, IN ACCORDANCE WITH
THE PRINCIPLE OF [
INDISCERNIBLE - HEAVY ACCENT ]
THE TREATY PLACES PRIMARY
RESPONSIBILITY AND CONTROL FOR
AIDING VICTIMS IN REMEDIATING
ENVIRONMENTS ON THE STATES
AFFECTED BY THE USE OR TEST OF
NUCLEAR WEAPONS.
THIS IS GROUNDBREAKING OF
COURSE.
HOWEVER SINCE THE NUCLEAR
WEAPONS ARE A THREAT TO THE
WHOLE HUMANITY, [ INDISCERNIBLE
- HEAVY ACCENT ] THIS IS THE
DUTY OF ALL PEOPLES.
THEREFORE, ARTICLE 7 EXPANDS
THE CIRCLE OF RESPONSIBILITY TO
ALL MEMBERS OF THE TREATY,
WHICH ARE REQUIRED TO COOPERATE
AND PROVIDE TECHNICAL MATERIAL
FOR INTERNATIONAL ASSISTANCE TO
HELP OTHERS MEET THEIR
OBLIGATIONS FOR MITIGATION.
IN ADDITION, ARTICLE 7.SUCCESS
THAT STATES JOINING THE TREATY
-- 7.6 THAT STATES JOIN THE
TREATY [ INDISCERNIBLE - HEAVY
ACCENT ] THIS IS
GROUNDBREAKING.
I WOULD LIKE TO MENTION SOME
ASPECTS OF THE PROCESS BECAUSE
THIS TREATY HAS MANY INDICATORS
OF SUCCESS IN INTERNATIONAL AND
DIDN'T -- DIPLOMATIC KEYS.
AS FAR AS WE ARE CONCERNED, THE
TREATY WAS NEGOTIATED IN THE
SHORTEST PERIOD.
THE PROCESS BENEFITED FROM
DIFFERENT DETERMINANTS I WOULD
LIKE TO MENTION.
FIRST OF ALL, WE HAD A VERY
CLEAR MIND -- TO COMBINE THIS
TO THE PROHIBITION AND NOT
START DEVELOPING THE PROCESSES
OF NUCLEAR DISARMAMENT WHICH
ARE COMPLETELY COMPLEX AND THAT
SHOULD BE DEVOTED TO ONCE THE
NEGOTIATING -- NUCLEAR STATES
ARE AT THE NEGOTIATING TABLE.
SECOND, THE CONFERENCE
BENEFITED FROM THE FACT THAT
THE RULES OF PROCEDURE OF THE
CONFERENCE WERE APPROVED FROM
DAY ONE, WHICH LEFT THE
DELEGATIONS WITH NO OTHER
OPTIONS BUT TO DEVOTE TO THE
DISCUSSION OF THE SUBSTANCE.
THIRD, THE CONFERENCE BENEFITED
FROM [ INDISCERNIBLE -
INTERMITTENT AUDIO ] AND
INCLUDED THE ROLE OF ACADEMIA
IN THE PROCESS.
THE CONFERENCE WAS INNOVATIVE
BECAUSE FOR THE FIRST TIME  WE
WERE ABLE TO OPEN [
INDISCERNIBLE - INTERMITTENT
AUDIO ] SCHOLARS, SCIENTISTS,
REPRESENTATIVES, VICTIMS OF THE
USE AND HIROSHIMA AND THAT
NAGASAKI -- AND AT NAGASAKI,
AND DELEGATIONS, SCIENTISTS.
THE FIRST  INFERENCE OF IT
BEING ACADEMIC WAS THAT WE
PROMOTED CONFRONTATION OF
IDEAS.
THAT WAS HELPFUL AND REFRESHING
FOR ALL THE DELEGATIONS. IT
HELPED IMPROVE THE KNOWLEDGE
CREATION MANAGEMENT CHANGE OF
ALL THE DELEGATIONS IN THE
CONFERENCE, WHICH WAS AND -- AN
OPENED AND INCLUSIVE PROCESS.
I DID INSTITUTE -- THIS
CONSISTED OF ADVISORS TO THE
PRESIDENCY FOR WHICH I RESORTED
TO SO THEY COULD GIVE ME FRESH
IDEAS IN THE ANALYSIS OF THE
PROCESS.
MANY TIMES I ASKED THEM,
SCHOLARS AND EXPERTS AND
SCIENTISTS, TO READ WHAT WE
WERE NEGOTIATING AND CONFRONT IT
. THEIR INPUT WITH THE
DELEGATIONS THAT WERE
NEGOTIATING -- SOMETIMES THE
DELEGATIONS DIDN'T LIKE THAT
VERY MUCH -- BUT AT THE END IT
WAS VERY SUCCESSFUL AND
HELPFUL.
SOME CAME TO ME AND SAID, WE ARE
GOVERNMENT.
WE ARE NOT HERE TO NEGOTIATE
WITH SCHOLARS. BUT IT WAS TRULY
HELPFUL TO BE ABLE TO EVERYDAY
STRESS THIS, THE MOST TECHNICAL
ASPECTS OF THE TREATY THAT WERE
BEING NEGOTIATED BY THE
DELEGATION.
I THINK OVERALL THE CONFERENCE
WAS ABLE TO AVERT MANY RISKS
THAT OPEN ON ITS OF THE TREATY
MENTIONED THE TREATY WOULD HAVE
, PRECISELY BECAUSE OF THAT
OPEN EXCHANGE BETWEEN ACADEMIA,
AND DELEGATIONS. LAST BUT NOT
LEAST, THE CONFERENCE WAS ABLE
TO BENEFIT FROM A VERY STRONG
POLITICAL DETERMINATION THAT
HAS BEEN FORGED THROUGHOUT THE
YEARS AND THAT GREW OUT OF THE
FRUSTRATION OF THESE 122, THE
MAJORITY OF THE INTERNATIONAL
COMMUNITY WITH A SLOW PACE
NEGOTIATING THE DISARMAMENT.
THIS DETERMINATION ALSO BENEFIT
-- BENEFITED FROM THE
INCREASING EVIDENCE, UPDATED
EVIDENCE OF THE SCIENTIFIC AND
DIPLOMATIC AND ACADEMIC
COMMITTEE.
THEY WERE ABLE TO EXCHANGE THIS
INFORMATION ABOUT THE
CONSEQUENCES OF NUCLEAR WEAPONS
AND WHAT EXACTLY THAT WOULD
MEAN TODAY, 2017, WHAT WOULD IT
MEAN TODAY TO HAVE A NUCLEAR
DETONATION.
THE SCIENTIFIC EVIDENCE WAS SO
HORRENDOUS FOR THE
INTERNATIONAL COMMUNITY THAT
THE INTERNATIONAL COMMUNITY
DECIDED THAT THE WAY IN WHICH
WE DISCUSS NUCLEAR DISARMAMENT
WOULD NOT BE ONLY FOCUSED ON
NUCLEAR DETERRENCE OR THE
DETERMINANTS OF NUCLEAR A SURE
DESTRUCTION, BUT IT WOULD HAVE
TO INCORPORATE THE DISCUSSION
ABOUT THE CATASTROPHIC
CONSEQUENCES.
THIS MOVEMENT GROUP ADULT TO
CLEAN -- GROUP POLITICALLY AND
SOCIALLY IN SUCH TERMS AT ALL
DELEGATIONS [ INDISCERNIBLE -
INTERMITTENT AUDIO ] IT WAS A
VERY SUPPORT -- VERY SUPPORTIVE
COALITION TO BRING THE TREATY
TO CONCLUSION VERY SOON.
[ INDISCERNIBLE - INTERMITTENT
AUDIO ] THE FACT THAT WE WERE
PERCEIVED AS AN HONEST BROKER
IN THE NEGOTIATION, MEANING
THAT WE WERE NOT NEUTRAL BUT
COMPLETELY COMMITTED TO THE
ACHIEVEMENT OF THE MANDATE. WE
WERE PERCEIVED AS AN HONEST
BROKER NOT ONLY BECAUSE OF THE
ROLE WE HAVE PLAYED BUT ALSO
BECAUSE I MYSELF HAVE NOT BEEN
ENGAGED IN NUCLEAR POLITICS
BEFORE. IT WAS A FRESH NEW
LEADERSHIP AND PEOPLE COULD NOT
ENCAPSULATE ME IN ONE THOUGHT
OR THE OTHER AND THAT GAVE ME
THE POSSIBILITY TO BRIDGE
POSITIONS.
LAST BUT NOT LEAST, OF COURSE
THE PRESIDENCY HAS TO PROMOTE
AT SOME POINT, HAS TO OFFER THE
CONFERENCE WITH PROPOSED TEXT.
THE CONFERENCE HAS TO NEGOTIATE
THE TEXT AND THE PRESIDENT HAS
TO UPDATE THAT TEXT THAT IS
UNDER DISCUSSION.
BUT THERE IS A POINT AT WHICH
THE PRESIDENT UNDERSTANDS THAT
THERE IS NO MORE ROOM NOT ONLY
IN TERMS OF TIME BUT ALSO
NEGOTIATION, MANEUVERING. WE
NEED THE CONFERENCE TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT WE HAVE BEFORE
US IS THE BEST DEAL WE CAN
ARRIVE AT AND TO CONVINCE THEM
THIS IS THE DEAL. AT SOME POINT
IT WAS VERY -- WE WILL ABLE TO
HAVE A SOLID GROUP OF THE VAST
MAJORITY OF THE INTERNATIONAL
COMMUNITY TO AGREE ON THIS
INTERNATIONAL NORM. FROM NOW ON
WE HAVE TO DEVOTE OURSELVES TO
STRENGTHENING AND DEVELOPING
THE LINKS, THE APPROPRIATE
LINKS WITH THE WRECKED -- WITH
THE REST, NUMBER OF RELATION --
NONPROLIFERATION OF NUCLEAR
WEAPONS AS WELL AS NUCLEAR
TESTING, AND THE REST OF THE
ARCHITECTURE OF BOTH
INSTITUTIONAL AND CONVENTIONAL
REGIMES THAT EXIST IN -- AT THE
U.N. LEVEL.
ABOVE ALL, WE DO HOPE THIS
TREATY IS GOING TO HELP GIVE A
VERY IMPORTANT POLITICAL PUSH
FOR DISARMAMENT NEGOTIATIONS
TOGETHER WITH THE URGENCY, THE
URGE THAT WE HAVE JUST READING
WHAT'S IN THE NEWS.
I WANT TO THANK YOU AND I AM
NOW READY FOR AN EXCHANGE IF
YOU WOULD LIKE TO ASK ME
QUESTIONS.
>>[ APPLAUSE ]
>> THANK YOU HIS EXCELLENCY
LUIS GUILLERMO SOLC RIVERA  --
PRESIDENT SOLC AND AMBASSADOR
WHITE.
I AM AT THE INSTITUTE OF LATIN
AMERICAN STUDIES AND I HAVE THE
HONOR TO MODERATE THESE Q&A
SESSION -- THIS Q&A SESSION.
AS YOU WILL SEE THERE ARE TWO
MICROPHONES ON THE AISLE.
WE ASK YOU TO PLEASE LINE UP
BEHIND THE MICROPHONES AND
STATE YOUR QUESTIONS.
PLEASE REMEMBER TO FIRST GIVE
YOUR NAME  AND YOUR SCHOOL
AFFILIATION SO THAT PRESIDENT
SOLC KNOWS WHO YOU ARE.
WHILE WE ARE WAITING I WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR THE GREAT  SPEECH
THAT YOU JUST GAVE US.
IT SEEMS LIKE WE SHOULD BE
LIVING IN A WORLD THAT SHOULD
THINK ABOUT THE WEAPON ICING
BUT IT SEEMS LIKE WE ARE IN A
WORLD THAT IS THINKING ABOUT AN
ARMS RACE.
>> WE CAN ONLY HOPE THAT MORE
NATIONS ACT LIKE YOURS, THAT
DON'T HAVE AN ARMY.
WHAT COULD MILITARIZED NATIONS
LEARN FROM DEMILITARIZED
NATIONS?
>> THE EXPERIENCE OF NOT HAVING
AN ARMY, I MUST ACKNOWLEDGE, IS
RATHER UNIQUE.
EVEN THOUGH I WOULD ADVISE ANY
COUNTRY TO ATTEMPT TO GO THAT
WAY, I REALIZE THAT IT MAY NOT
BE POSSIBLE.
SOMETIMES EVEN THE NOTION OF
THE NATIONSTATE IS BUILT UPON
THE USE OF ARMS, THE NEED TO
LIBERATE A NATION WHICH IS
CLEARLY THE CASE OF THE UNITED
STATES AND SOME OTHERS.
I ALWAYS HAVE, WHEN I ADDRESS
THIS ISSUE, I'M ALWAYS VERY
CAREFUL NOT TO GIVE COUNSEL AND
SPEAK IN GENERAL TERMS BECAUSE
IT CAN BE A PROBLEM.
BEING A HISTORIAN, THIS IS
SOMETHING I TAKE VERY SERIOUSLY.
IN OUR EXPERIENCE, HAVING THIS
IS A PERMANENT INSTITUTION,
IT'S ALLOWING US TO USE OUR
BUDGET ELSEWHERE.
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT THE
DIVIDENDS OF PEACH -- PIECE
WHICH IS DEFINITE -- PEACE
WHICH IS USUALLY ASSOCIATED WITH
POSTWAR TIMES.
WE HAVE BEEN ABLE TO USE THE
SCARCE RESOURCES OF THE COUNTRY
IN A DIFFERENT WAY.  THAT IS
ONE THING.
THE SECOND THING, IT HAS
PROVIDED STABILITY IN THE
REGION , THE LATIN AMERICAN
REGION WHERE THE ARMED FORCES
HAVE BEEN GENERALLY ASSOCIATED
WITH POSING SERIOUS DANGERS TO
INSTITUTIONS, DEMOCRATIC
INSTITUTIONS AND GOVERNMENTS.
>> YES, GO AHEAD.
>> THANK YOU VERY MUCH
PRESIDENT SOLC AND AMBASSADOR
WHITE  FOR COMING AND SPEAKING
TODAY.
I AM A STUDENT IN COLUMBIA
COLLEGE STUDYING LITERATURE.
AS SOMEONE HERE BOTH IN
ACADEMIA AND ALSO OUT IN THE
WORLD, I WAS IMPRESSED WITH
YOUR DEDICATION PLEDGING TO
ACADEMIC A TOTAL ACADEMIA,
ESPECIALLY THE NEGOTIATIONS --
PLEDGING TO ACADEMICS,
ESPECIALLY NEGOTIATIONS ABOUT
DISARMAMENT.
I WOULD LIKE TO KNOW HOW YOU
THINK WE CAN HELP THEM TO COME
AROUND AND AND NOT SO POLITICAL
QUESTION IS WHAT IS YOUR
FAVORITE LIST WE CAN ARTIST OR
WRITER?
>> BELIEVE IT OR NOT I AM ALSO
PLACING A LOT OF HOPE IN
ACADEMIA TO HELP US IN THIS
PROCESS BECAUSE IT'S TRUE THAT
IT HAS BEEN A DIVISIVE DIALOGUE
. THE NUCLEAR WEAPONS STATES
DID NOT BELIEVE THAT THE REST
OF THE COMMUNITY, THE
INTERNATIONAL COMMUNITY HAD TO
MOVE THIS FORWARD. IN BUILDING
BRIDGES, I THINK ACADEMIA IS
VERY WELL-PLACED IN ORDER TO
PROVIDE US WITH ANALYSIS. THIS
HELPS US WITH BUILDING BRIDGES
TO HAVE THE PROPER COORDINATION
BETWEEN THE BAN TREATY AND THE
ARCHITECTURE.
WE ALREADY HAVE ARCHITECTURES
THAT HAVE DIFFERENT INSTITUTIONS
-- [ INDISCERNIBLE - LOW VOLUME
] IT'S VERY DIFFICULT BECAUSE I
LOVE MUSIC.
>> IN GENERAL, WRITERS ARE A
CREATIVE FORCE THAT CAN INSPIRE.
>> IT IS VERY DIFFICULT BECAUSE
I LOVE MUSIC AND WE HAVE VERY
GOOD MUSICIANS.
I AM AFRAID THAT I WOULD LEAVE
SOME BEHIND.
LET ME JUST MENTION A COUPLE OF
THEM BECAUSE THEY ARE
INTERNATIONAL AMBASSADORS OF
COSTA RICA.
ONE OF THEM IS CALLED [ NAME
INDISCERNIBLE ] WHO IS A PIANIST
. HE IS A COMPOSER AS WELL.
HE HAS MADE THIS VERY BEAUTIFUL
INTERACTION BETWEEN MUSIC AND
NATURE AND HAS BEAUTIFUL
COMPOSITIONS DEVOTED TO THE
RAIN FOREST AND THE DANGERS OF
DESTRUCTION OF THE RAIN FOREST.
SYMBIOSIS IS A PIANO ARRANGEMENT
WITH NATURE IMAGERY SOUNDS AND
IT'S VERY BEAUTIFUL.
THE OTHER ONE IS CARLOS -- WHO
IS ALSO A COMPOSER.
HE'S ABLE TO COMPOSE FOLK MUSIC
WITH CLASSICAL INSTRUMENTS.
HE ALSO HAS CREATED VERY
BEAUTIFUL PIECES.
>> I WILL MAKE A BRIEF COMMENT
ON ACADEMIA AND POLITICS AND
GENERAL INTERNATIONAL POLITICS.
I WAS VERY FORTUNATE TO BE ABLE
TO PARTICIPATE AS ONE OF THE
COSTA RICAN NEGOTIATORS IN THE
CENTRAL AMERICAN PEACE PLAN IN
1986 AND 1987.
I WAS A VERY YOUNG DIPLOMAT AT
THE TIME.
IT ALWAYS IMPACTED ME A LOT HOW
ACADEMIA WAS A BRIDGE BETWEEN
THINKING AND DECISION-MAKING.
THAT WAS THE CAPACITY OF
ACADEMIA TO ORDER PROCESSES, TO
BE ABLE TO SEE, PUT ISSUES IN A
WIDER SCHEME OF THINGS. I THINK
ESPECIALLY IN NEGOTIATED
INTERNATIONAL AFFAIRS,
INTERNATIONAL MATTERS, IT IS
VERY IMPORTANT TO HAVE MORE
OPTIONS OPEN THEN LAST.
YOU HAVE TO CONTINUE -- THAN
LESS. YOU HAVE TO CONTINUE TO
HAVE MANY OPPORTUNITIES.
IF YOU DON'T HAVE SOCIAL OR
NATURAL SCIENCES INVOLVED, YOUR
SCOPE TENDS TO BE MUCH LIMITED
AND REDUCED.
I THINK THAT ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT ACADEMICS AND PEOPLE WHO
ARE KEEN OF KNOWLEDGE ARE ABLE
TO DO IS ABLE -- IS TO BE ABLE
TO PUT THAT IN A MORE BROADER
SENSE.
THE SECOND THING IS  YOU ARE
BETTER POISED NOT TO REPEAT
ERRORS OF THE PAST, IF YOU KNOW
YOUR HISTORY WELL.
THIRDLY, YOU CAN COMPARE WHICH
IS ANOTHER THING THAT IS VERY
IMPORTANT. YOU SEEK FOR
PROCESSES THAT ARE COMPARABLE
AND THEREFORE CAN BE RELEVANT
TO THE SOLUTION.
AGAIN, AS MEN AMBASSADOR HAS
MENTIONED, I WILL -- MADAM
AMBASSADOR HAS MENTIONED, I
WILL MENTION SOMEONE WHO IS
INTERNATIONAL AND WELL-KNOWN.
THEY HAVE ONE A GRAMMY AWARD
AND ARE WELL-KNOWN FOR THAT
REASON.
IN WRITING, I'M GOING TO
MENTION THE MOST AND CITED
COSTA RICAN AUTHOR, CARLOS
FALLAS. HE WROTE A BOOK IN THE
1940S CALLED [ SPANISH BEING
SPOKEN ] WHICH IS THE WAY THE
FORMER BANANA WORKERS
PRONOUNCED UNITED FOR UNITED
FRUIT COMPANY. IT IS A DEPICTION
OF THE LIFE OF THE COSTA RICAN
BANANA WORKERS AND -- IN THE
BANANA ENCLAVES OF THE 1930S.
THAT HAS CHANGED A LOT BUT THE
WORK OF CARLOS FALLAS  HAS BEEN
WELL KNOWN AND WELL TAKEN.
>> GOOD MORNING.
THANK YOU SO MUCH PRESIDENT
SOLC AND AMBASSADOR FOR
LEADING THIS TREATY.
TRYING TO FIND OUT, TO PROTECT
THE WORLD, GLOBAL PEACE. MY
QUESTION IS ABOUT, I KNOW THAT
LATIN AMERICA, ALMOST EVERY
COUNTRY IN LATIN AMERICA SIGNED
THIS TREATY INCLUDING MY HOME
COUNTRY OF VENEZUELA. MY
QUESTION IS ABOUT THIS.
WHICH MECHANISM OF THE TREATY
DOES IT HAVE TO PREVENT TO
PREVENT COUNTRIES LIKE VENEZUELA
FROM SIGNING THIS TREATY AND
THEN THE INTERNATIONAL
COMMUNITY, [ INDISCERNIBLE -
HEAVY ACCENT ] IT'S NOT SECRET
THAT VENEZUELA HAS CLOSE
RELATIONSHIPS WITH IRAN AND
NORTH KOREA. VENEZUELA CAN
PROVIDE THE RADIUM MAY NEED TO
CREATE THESE NUCLEAR WEAPONS.
BY THE WAY, THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR EVERYTHING THAT YOU HAVE
DONE TO HELP MY PEOPLE IN
VENEZUELA. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
>> THE TREATY ACTUALLY HAS A
REINFORCEMENT OF NORMS THAT ARE
PLACED IN OTHER INSTRUMENTS
SUCH AS THE TREATY TO WHICH
VENEZUELA IS A PARTY.
THE TREATY RELIES ON THE SAME
SYSTEM OF VERIFICATION AND
SAFEGUARDS THAT WAS ALREADY
CREATED FOR THE TREATY OF THE
NONPROLIFERATION.
IT INCLUDES THE POSSIBILITY OF
DEVELOPING NEW STANDARDS IN
TERMS OF SAFEGUARDS.
EVERY COUNTRY THAT SIGNS THIS
AND VENEZUELA ALREADY DID, IS
COMMITTED TO HAVING THE SAME
SAFEGUARDS AGREEMENT THAT IT
ALREADY HAS WITH THE
INTERNATIONAL ATOMIC ENERGY
ASSOCIATION.
THERE IS NO POSSIBILITY OF
REGIME SHOPPING IN THIS REGARD.
THE NONPROLIFERATION
VERIFICATION SYSTEM APPLIES
ALSO FOR THIS CASE.
>> I THINK WE SHOULD GIVE
CREDIT TO LATIN AMERICA FOR
BEING AT THE FOREFRONT OF THE
FIGHT AGAINST NUCLEAR WEAPONS.
SINCE 1968, LATIN AMERICA
FORGED A LOCAL AGREEMET THAT
BANS PRODUCTION AND KEEPING AND
THE LIST OF THINGS THAT THE
AMBASSADOR MENTIONED, OF
WEAPONS OF MASS DESTRUCTION,
NUCLEAR WEAPONS IN PARTICULAR.
WE EVEN HAVE A MECHANISM THAT
IS A VERIFICATION MECHANISM FOR
THE TREATY.
I THINK THAT ALL LATIN AMERICAN
COUNTRIES HAVE BEEN VERY MUCH
ENGAGED IN THIS FOR A LONG
TIME.
IT'S A GOOD EXAMPLE THAT WE
WOULD LIKE TO POINT THAT'S
BECAUSE IT MAKES IT CLEAR AND A
COUNTRY CAN DISRESPECT THE
COMMUNITY BUT THE SANCTIONS AND
MECHANISMS ARE IN PLACE.
>> HELLO MR. PRESIDENT.
THANK YOU FOR SPEAKING TO US
TODAY.
MY NAME IS RICARDO TAVERAS.
I STUDY RISK MANAGEMENT AT THE
SCHOOL OF PROFESSIONAL STUDIES.
I WANTED TO ASK YOU A QUESTION
IN TERMS OF CYBER SECURITY.
WE UNDERSTAND THAT NOWADAYS
IT'S A VERY PROMINENT TOPIC.
THE NOTION THAT SOMEBODY THAT'S
HIGHLY TRAINED AND WITH ENOUGH
RESOURCES CAN JUST HACK THE
ACCESS TO NUCLEAR WEAPONS, HOW
ARE YOU HELPING MITIGATE THE
THREATS OF CYBER SECURITY WITH
REGARDS TO NUCLEAR WEAPONS?
IN ANOTHER, NOT A POLITICAL
QUESTION, IF YOU HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE LUNCH WITH
ANYBODY IN HISTORY, WHO WOULD
THAT BE AND WHY?
THANK YOU.
>> SURE! DO YOU WANT TO ADDRESS
THE CYBERSECURITY?
DID YOU TALK ABOUT THIS IN THE
NEGOTIATIONS?
>> YES, INDEED.
THE VAST MAJORITY OF THE
INTERNATIONAL COMMUNITY, THE
ONLY ASSURANCE WE HAVE VIS-C-VIS
CYBERSECURITY AND OTHER THREATS
IS TOTAL ELIMINATION OF NUCLEAR
WEAPONS BUT IT'S THE ONLY
ASSURANCE THAT WE HAVE.
>> REGARDING LUNCH WITH A
HISTORICAL FIGURE, I HAVE A
LONG LIST I CAN GIVE YOU.
I CAN GIVE YOU A LONG LIST OF
FIGURES.
I'VE BEEN ASKED THAT QUESTION
SEVERAL TIMES.
MY REGULAR ANSWER IS GANDHI. I
WOULD'VE LIKE TO HAVE LUNCH --
WOULD HAVE LIKED TO HAVE LUNCH
WITH HIM.
I HAVE A COUPLE MORE.
ONE IS A WOMAN I HAVE ALWAYS
CONSIDERED A VERY POWERFUL
FIGURE THAT I WOULD HAVE LIKED
TO HAVE KNOWN, MUCH MORE TO
HAVE LUNCH WITH HER.
THAT WOULD BE IN HER KITCHEN
BECAUSE SHE IS SUPPOSED TO BE
THE PERSON WHO INVENTED THE
KITCHEN CABINET WHICH IS GOLDA
MEIR, THE FORMER PRIME MINISTER
OF ISRAEL.
THE OTHER CHARACTER THAT IS
CLOSER TO US, I MET HIM SEVERAL
TIMES BUT NEVER FOR LUNCH AND I
WOULD LIKE TO SEE HIM AGAIN IN
THAT SAME CHARACTER, YOUR
FORMER PRESIDENT BARACK OBAMA.
>> GO AHEAD.
>> THANK YOU MR. PRESIDENT AND
MADAM AMBASSADOR FOR SPEAKING
WITH US.
MY NAME IS DOCTOR SONIA AND I
AM A STUDENT AT THE SCHOOL OF
INTERNATIONAL AND PUBLIC
AFFAIRS.
I DEEPLY ADMIRE YOUR STANDARDS
THAT FURTHER REGIONAL STABILITY
AND GLOBAL HARMONY.
MY QUESTION TO YOU IS, THE
NUCLEAR BAN TREATY IS EXPECTED
TO BE HAMPERED BY THE TREATIES
MENTIONED BY YOU, THE
NONPROLIFERATION TREATY WHICH
HAS AN INHERENT BIAS AGAINST
THE COUNTRIES THAT ARE NOT [
INDISCERNIBLE - HEAVY ACCENT ]
HOW DO YOU PROPOSE ADDRESSING
THAT?
MR. PRESIDENT, I WOULD LIKE TO
HAVE LUNCH WITH MR. GANDHI TOO.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> WE WILL GO TOGETHER.
TO I WOULD LOVE THAT.
THANK YOU.
>> I AM SORRY, CAN YOU REPEAT
YOUR QUESTION?
>> THE NUCLEAR BAN TREATY IS
SUPPOSED TO BE HAMPERED BY
FORMER TREATY SUCH AS THE
NUCLEAR NONPROLIFERATION
TREATY.
THESE HAVE AN INHERENT BIAS
AGAINST THE COUNTRIES THAT ARE
NOT -- [ INDISCERNIBLE - HEAVY
ACCENT ] HOW DO YOU PLAN ON
ADDRESSING THAT IN THE NUCLEAR
BAN TREATY?
. IT WAS VERY IMPORTANT THAT
THIS TREATY NOT BE A
DISCRIMINATORY TREATY.
THAT'S A REASON YOU DON'T SEE
DIFFERENT KIND OF LEGAL
OBLIGATIONS FOR DIFFERENT KINDS
OF COUNTRIES. ON THE CONTRARY,
EVERY STATE THAT SIGNS IS TO
ABIDE BY THE RULES. THERE IS OF
COURSE, THE NUCLEAR WEAPONS
PROCESSING WHICH NEEDS TO BE
ACCOMPANIED BY THE
INTERNATIONAL COMMUNITY.
IN GENERAL TERMS, LET'S SAY
IT'S AT LEAST 50 YEARS THAT
SEPARATES ONE TREATY FROM THE
OTHER.
WE ARE COMING FROM A DIFFERENT
PERSPECTIVE AND ALSO DEPARTING
FROM THE PERSPECTIVE THAT AN
INVENTION -- THE ILLUMINATION
OF NUCLEAR WEAPONS IS A PROMISE.
THE NUCLEAR WEAPON STATES PUT
THIS ON THE TABLE. THERE IS THE
PROMISE THAT NATIONS WILL
ELIMINATE NUCLEAR WEAPONS.
WE HAVE DEPARTED FROM THAT,
THAT IT IS NECESSARY FOR ALL
COUNTRIES OF THE WORLD BECAUSE
OF THE DISAGREEMENTS IN THE
PAST TREATY.
MANY OF THE COUNTRIES ARE
ALREADY TAKING PART IN REGIONAL
TREATIES FOR THE DECLARATION OF
NUCLEAR WEAPONS ZONES.
WE HAVE THEREFORE DEPARTED FROM
REGIONAL TREATIES TO A GLOBAL
NORM THAT BRINGS TOGETHER ALL
OF THESE COUNTRIES.
IT REINFORCES THE
NONPROLIFERATION.
>> GO AHEAD.
>> MY NAME IS ANDREW AND I AM
STUDYING PREMED FOR NOW.
A FEW PEOPLE HAVE SUGGESTED THAT
BEFORE THE MIDTERMS I WILL HAVE
TO SWITCH TO BUSINESS OR
INTERNATIONAL AFFAIRS BUT WE
WILL DEAL WITH THAT WHEN ME GET
TO THAT POINT.
I APPRECIATE YOUR WORK DEALING
WITH NUCLEAR ARMS PROLIFERATION
ETC.
MY NUMBER 1 CONCERN IS I AM
TAKING FULL ADVANTAGE OF THE
FORM THIS WEEKEND I WENT TO THE
WORLD HEALTH ORGANIZATION
CONFERENCE THE OTHER DAY.
THEIR NUMBER 1 CONCERN IS
FIGHTING THE ZIKA VIRUS.
THIS IS A MAJOR THREAT TO LATIN
AMERICA, TO YOUR BACKYARD. MY
IMMEDIATE THOUGHT IS THE CANAL
THAT'S BEING DONE IN NICARAGUA.
IF YOU UNDERSTAND THE HISTORY
OF THE PANAMA CANAL, MOSQUITOES
BEING THE NUMBER 1 KILLER, I
WOULD LIKE TO KNOW HOW YOU GUYS
PLAN TO ADDRESS BIOLOGICAL
WARFARE, AS WELL AS YOUR WORK
WITH THE NUCLEAR ARMS. SECOND
OF ALL, I'M NOT REALLY
INTERESTED IN WHO YOU GUYS ARE
HAVING LUNCH WITH IN THE
FUTURE.
INTERESTED IN WHO YOU ARE
HAVING LUNCH WITH TODAY.
WILL YOU HAVE LUNCH WITH ME?
>> [ LAUGHTER ] THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
ABSOLUTELY!
ON THE ZIKA VIRUS, YES, IT IS A
BIG CONCERN FOR ALL COUNTRIES,
NOT ONLY THE TROPICAL AREAS.
AS YOU KNOW, IN FACT ALSO ZIKA
HAS A PRESENCE IN TEMPERATE
COUNTRIES SUCH AS UNITED STATES
AND EUROPE. THE ONLY WAY TO
HANDLE THAT IS THROUGH EDUCATION
, IN THE ULTIMATE ANALYSIS.
IT DEPENDS ON CONTROLLING THE
VECTORS.
THE WAY TO DO THAT IS
PREVENTING THE MOSQUITOES TO
LAY THEIR EGGS IN STANDING
WATER AND THINGS LIKE THAT.
IN URBAN AREAS, WE HAVE BEEN
DEALING WITH COMMUNITIES MAKING
THEM UNDERSTAND THE NEED TO
DISPOSE OF WATER, ESPECIALLY IN
PLACES LIKE COSTA RICA WHERE WE
HAVE A LONG AND INTENSE RAINY
SEASON.
THAT'S ONE THING.
I THINK W.H.O.
AS WELL AS THE REGIONAL HEALTH
ORGANIZATIONS ARE DOING A GOOD
JOB.
ZIKA IS BY AND LARGE BEING
DEALT WITH QUITE SUCCESSFULLY,
EVEN WHEN THE CASES ARE STILL
VERY ABUNDANT.
REGARDING THE CANAL IN NICARAGUA
, WE THOUGHT THEY WERE GOING TO
BUILD A CANAL IN NICARAGUA BUT
IT'S NOT BEING BUILT.
IT SEEMS TO HAVE BEEN A HOAX
FROM JOE POLITIC. THERE ARE
MANY THINGS BEING DONE IN
NICARAGUA BUT NOT THE CANAL.
REGARDING BIOLOGICAL WARFARE,
THAT'S A DIFFERENT AREA OF
INTERNATIONAL CONCERN.
I THINK THERE ARE OTHER
GROUPINGS OF COUNTRIES THAT ARE
DEALING WITH THAT.
I WOULD LIKE TO USE YOUR
QUESTION TO HIGHLIGHT THE FACT
THAT BEING SUCH A SIGNIFICANT
ISSUE, NUCLEAR WEAPONS, FOR THE
FUTURE OF THE WORLD, THESE
OTHER ISSUES THAT YOU BRING UP
HAVE MORE IMMEDIATE IMPACT ON
DAILY LIFE.
NUCLEAR WEAPONS AND THE USE OF
NUCLEAR WEAPONS, LET'S HOPE
IT'S UNLIKELY. GENERALLY, WE DO
NOT THINK IT'S GOING TO HAPPEN,
UNTIL IT HAPPENS.
BUT THESE OTHER ISSUES, ZIKA,
CHEMICAL WEAPONS, CLIMATE CHANGE
, AND THE THINGS WE DON'T DO
AND WHAT WOULD HAPPEN IF WE
DON'T TAKE MEASURES ARE MORE
IMMEDIATE.
THEY ARE THINGS THAT ARE
HAPPENING AS WE SPEAK.
THE USE OF REGULAR WEAPONS,
COSTA RICA TOOK PART IN A VERY
STRONG CAMPAIGN TO CONTROL
REGULAR WEAPONS, THE ONES THAT
PEOPLE USED TO KILL STUDENTS IN
SCHOOLS AND UNIVERSITIES, OR TO
DO ILLEGAL THINGS IN THE STREETS
. FOR THIS WE ALSO RECEIVED
HIGH INTERNATIONAL PRAISE UNDER
THE IDS ADMINISTRATION A FEW
YEARS BACK.
WE OUGHT TO LOOK, AS YOU
MENTIONED, TO OTHER ISSUES OF
WORLD CONCERN THAT ALSO KILL
PEOPLE, AND THEY DO SO IN LARGE
NUMBERS.
REGARDING LUNCH, I'M AFRAID WE
WILL HAVE TO GO TO THE AIRPORT
FROM HERE. IT WILL HAVE TO BE
NEXT TIME BUT IT WOULD BE
DELIGHTFUL TO HAVE LUNCH WITH
YOU.
>> NEXT TIME, I CAN HOLD YOU TO
THAT.
THANK YOU.
>> UNFORTUNATELY WE HAVE RUN
OUT OF TIME.
I WOULD LIKE TO THANK YOU
PRESIDENT SOLC AND AMBASSADOR
WHITE FOR TAKING THE TIME TO
COME AND VISIT US IN A VERY
BUSY WEEK I'M SURE, AND TO GIVE
US SUCH AN INSIGHTFUL SPEECH ON
THE TOPIC THAT IS SO RELEVANT
TO THE WORLD RIGHT NOW.
I THINK I CAN SPEAK FOR ALL OF
US HERE, WE CAN ONLY HOPE THAT
MORE NATIONS COULD BE US FOR
THINKING AS YOURS.
FOR THAT WE THANK YOU.
>> THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
>> [ APPLAUSE ]
>> LADIES AND GENTLEMEN, PLEASE
REMAIN IN YOUR SEATS AS WE
EXPORT THE PRESIDENT -- ESCORT
THE PRESIDENT AND HIS
DELEGATION OUT OF THE ROOM.
THANK YOU.